most important thing in people's lives
and their greatest accomplishment should not be their children
Chloe and I agree but let's talk about why the idea that especially for women
your greatest accomplishment in life should be your children is outdated
my mom raised me to know that she was a woman first and a mother second
she would tell me
you're not my greatest achievement never mess me up or offended me
I understood that she was just tryna raise us girls to understand that
even if we didn't have children
we weren't missing out we weren't not fulfilling our best selves or not
we we weren't purposeless that we could go and do anything
and having children might be one of those things
might be one really amazing thing and it might not be
and she never wanted us to feel limited
but that's what that kind of sentiment does it does limit women
I'm gonna explain why I'm Doctor Zoe
I have a PhD in feminism and I really wanna talk about this
women are expected
to say that having children is their biggest accomplishment in life
and we have these Women's weekends every year in my family
and the women like share their biggest accomplishments
we do cards we do like d and m's and the women always say like
my biggest accomplishment's my children my mom's always said like
mine isn't and everyone in the room's always kind of a bit like
did you really say that
especially back in the day
you know it was a shocking thing to say
but what is an amazing profound experience
I imagine I mean
I have my fur baby so I can imagine uh
it is not the Beal and endor
but people
rarely tell men that their greatest accomplishment in life should be
having a child has anyone ever asked you if your greatest accomplishment in life
should be having a child no
ha ha
when we continue to normalise this statement
what we're doing is perpetuating this limited idea of womanhood
that unless you do experience being a mother
that you will not achieve your biggest uh
I guess you won't be a fulfilled
complete person do you feel like you were your mom's greatest achievement
no
are you offended by the content of this TikTok as a man